USA Today Washington bureau chief Susan
page covered George HW Bush since 1980
the presidential campaign she's also
working on a biography of Barbara Bush
and she joins us from our Washington
bureau this morning Susan good morning
hey it's great to be with you you can't
help but but look at this extraordinary
life that the that the late President
had I mean first of all his resume
politically was was was it was almost
unparalleled even his marriage was epic
wasn't it it's true it's a it's a
remarkable American story from his
enlisting to go into in harm's way
during World War two on his 18th
birthday when his dad took him to New
York to it to enlist to meeting Barbara
Bush and at a high school Christmas
dance and then marrying they never
really she used to say that it was she
she married the first guy she ever
kissed which she said would make her
grandchildren want to throw up they had
they did have a remarkable union
and-and-and the end so sweet in it and
sad isn't it that that mrs. Bush would
die in April and then that he would
follow here at the end of November Susan
he was called the most consequential
president one-term president what made
him so effective in just four years you
know I think that with the benefit of a
little bit of hindsight with George HW
Bush's presidency he looks bigger than
he did at the time he left office he
looks more successful more consequential
because of the skill with which he
handled the end of the Cold War you know
that was a treacherous time full of
risks possible to make missteps but he
was very well designed he was oh he was
meant to be there for the end of the
Cold War because of his experience in
his his ability to do diplomacy with
such skill and then of course repelling
the Iraqi invasion of Kuwait also a big
part of his legacy I think also you know
his civility resounds in an important
way now we remember how civil things
were it wasn't a Golden Age of
bipartisanship
but compared to today it looks like
there are some lessons to be learned
there's no doubt about it and there are
so many things with his foreign policy
that are looked at in that one term but
also domestically things that people
forget about the Clean Air Act and also
working on the American with
Disabilities Act and having that lasting
impact as well you know and another
thing he was a groundbreaker when it
came to aids I think it's easy to forget
the stigma attached to hiv/aids at the
time he took office and and this was
something that Barbara Bush also urged
him to do I think in retrospect that
also is part of his legacy so there were
some things that involved serving others
that really are threads through his
public service through its family as
well no Susan you mention we mentioned
that you're working on a biography of a
Barbara Bush and and you interviewed the
president for that in November of last
year and what did you take away from
that conversation you know I didn't push
many times over the years he was in fact
the first national politician I ever
interviewed in 1980 during the first
presidential campaign I ever covered and
then to see him again what 37 years
later it toward the end of his life he
was when I interviewed him last November
almost exactly a year ago he was
struggling with the effects of Park in
the form of Parkinson's disease that he
that he had he could understand it could
speak but only short sentences but we
taught what we were talking about in
that very final interview was his wife
and about what had attracted him to her
and what amount of why their marriage
lasted so long and what role she had
played in his success and I said do you
remember when you saw her for the first
time at that Christmas dance in
Greenwich Connecticut and he said I
remember I said well what drew your eye
and he said she was so beautiful
Oh Jeb Bush said it the front row seat
to the most amazing loves all right it's
so true it's so true it's just it's an
extraordinary life and in the end also a
very humble man yeah so many ways for
all that he did and did for this country
we will have much more on the death of
George Herbert Walker Bush the 41st
president United
dates in our next hour Bob Schieffer
will join us to talk about his memories
of the 41st president and you can always
find the latest on CBS news.com and on
our streaming network cbsn and/or thanks
of course to Susan Paige